yeah so
so you were making a shitload of money
and you started getting worried like
this
could go south very quickly i remember
one day one day of all places i was
sitting on a toilet and
i had this overwhelming sense it just
came over me and i was like i just felt
flushed like i realized like i was like
if i don't stop doing this
there's going to be a problem you know i
i just i
i don't know like i'm not clear of when
or anything i just i just
i just knew that like i was i was
operating in gray area we got multiple
letters from the fda
so the fda sent us letters saying stop
selling this product
or we can bring criminal action against
you and i would rip them up and throw
them in the trash
you know i wouldn't talk to a lawyer and
i was like can they really do this this
lawyer is not a federal lawyer
but he's like no as long as it's not
scheduled you're good
if it's not like an illegal ban
substance all i can do is threaten you
and it wasn't an illegal ban
it wasn't at the time no it wasn't but
that you know they would tell us like
it's going to be scheduled people are
misusing this their letter would say
like people are consuming this
as a drug it produces
uh undesirable effects it's dangerous
stop
selling it so the fda will send you
warnings they'll tell you stop selling
the product
how long did this last when you were
making twenty thousand dollars a day
about a year we so what what happened
was
there was another product on the shelves
and it came in a little pack two little
red pills had a look like the walmart
smiley face
and happy time pills some people some of
them just at happy times
mr happy mr nice guys are the same stuff
uh well
mr nice guy k2 happy
meth alone knock off molly
okay so that's when the dea the dea
didn't
ever do anything as far as i know their
investigation didn't even involve the
jwh-18
fda didn't like the synthetic
cannabinoids
dea drew the line in the sand at molly
so when they see you know people are
taking this club drug
people overdose on this stuff this is
dangerous the dea gets involved
and that's when that's when uh
we we experience the problems so you
know
we got indicted on bk mdma methylene
that is what the dea indicted us on that
is like
synthetic moly or like you said bath
salts people call it whatever
so up until the point you got indicted
like what what was the process like to
where you
first realized like [ __ ] we might be in
some [ __ ] to the point
where you finally got indicted like what
was it was it was it instantaneous did
it happen like
the next day it was instantaneous but
you know i did have my intuition like
i remember i got an email from the
supplier that asked for a phone number
wanted to talk and i was like wait a
minute did somehow to the federal
government
and like somehow crack their pgp and
like
this just seems fishy but it was such a
big order it was like 300 kilos
so it was such a big order that even
though it seemed fishy i took the bait
so definitely was baited at the time i
wanted to
i was sitting in county jail and i'm
thinking like was i honey potted
like did somehow the federal government
set up a honey pot in china and
like it just seemed weird how you know
how it all came about did you get some
some prostitutes in china
no no isn't that what a honeypot is when
they try to get some hot chick
what i meant by that is like they set up
like a sting operation or a honeypot
where they would like
they facilitate the drug trade and so
the government actually sets up an
offshore entity facilitates a drug trade
lets you
get big so that they can knock your head
off once you get to the point where
you're on their radar oh okay i thought
i thought that maybe i'm thinking of a
honey trap maybe there's a difference
so did you actually go to china to check
out this company no no you never went
there nope
wow nope so uh it wasn't necessary
so what what was it like the day that
you found out you were [ __ ]
oh a size 12 military boot on the side
of your head
fully automatic weapons and your face
how did they walk me through that day
oh they laying in bed they kicked the
door in
um like early in the morning late at
night
midday was like right it was like 10
o'clock 10 o'clock in the morning and
you're in orlando
in orlando they kicked the door in um
people all over the lawn i mean all up
the street
they had i mean it was just crazy people
with video cameras
um there's no warning they don't knock
you know they just kick the door in they
come in with guns from all angles
they throw you on the ground they bust
all your doors they rip doors off the
hinges they destroy the place
and they hold you to the ground with a
you know a huge military boot
until they zip tie your hands and then
throw you in the back of a dog catcher
and take you
in for questioning [ __ ]
they beat you up a little bit when they
did that no i mean no
no that's good well besides the guy's
boot
i mean they're not they're not gentle
but uh you know the way they see it in
the way if you read that article
at the department of justice they paint
me like i'm some el chapo so what
happened after they knocked your
your door down put the zip ties around
your
your legs and your wrists and threw you
in the back of the pad just your wrist
they just throw it around
yeah so they take you to a holding cell
downtown it's in the courthouse
they uh they ask you questions they they
try to scare you they
you know they they they talk a lot of
crap
they say they got you dead to right they
try to convince you to tell them
something
of course if you're smart you'll keep
your mouth shut what did you do it kept
my mouth shut
i demanded to speak to my lawyer first
at the time
my lawyer wasn't a federal lawyer so he
never represented a federal client so
he when i talked to him he said listen
man
this is way over my head he said i can
refer you to somebody
who can help you and he referred me to
mark and james and this guy charged me
thirty thousand dollars
um just as a consultant that's cheap
you know when if you actually go to
trial like donovan davis went to trial
i think he had two lawyers and
he ended up spending over a million
dollars
on his legal defense so and so you still
had access to your money
well yeah so not all of my money they
didn't seize your bank accounts or
anything no they did
so the wells fargo account they they
closed it down i couldn't access it
anymore
they seized a lot of cash um
from the business and from from my
personal property they seized all of my
assets my computers my electronics
they took everything so vehicles they
took it all
um so but i
i not all of my income was
generated illegitimately you know i'm
still making money legally
i have clients i had a client in punta
gorda
a doctor i was 60 grand a year i had a
client
doing what web development web
development video production right
different marketing services and i had
another
client who was like a lifestyle coach so
i had revenue coming in that was legal
they couldn't touch that
and i also had serpify so you know at
the time making money legitimately the
feds can't
touch your money that you're making
legitimately they can only take what
they can prove
you're not supposed to have yeah by
their you okay
so uh you're sitting in the cell they're
trying to scare the [ __ ] out of you
trying to get you to confess everything
and you call your lawyer
and uh what did he say like what were
you looking at so
he said that i was looking at five years
as
he said look he said if you
he said he said before you say anything
before we do anything
i need to see the evidence they have
against you i need to know whether or
not he like i can't tell you what to do
i can't tell you to go to trial or not
go to trial that's going to be your
decision
but i can tell you what i would do if i
was in your shoes i could tell you what
i would do based on the evidence they
have against me
and the the the time that you're facing
when it all came down he he looked at
everything he said well you know
loosely scheduled substance it's not you
know it's not like crack cocaine or
something with a stiff sentence he said
they're gonna base it on the marijuana
equivalency table they do this ratio
adjustment based on the based on the
quantity and you know they did that in
our case too so
since the 151 months but then when the
dea toxicology report
came back that showed our substance was
actually less than half as potent
as what they initially thought it was
they had to
they had to do a three or four level
departure based on that
equivalency based on that rate based on
what their toxicology report showed it
as
so that of course helped so they were
charging you based on
because it was the closest to weed right
so they were saying
you have this x amount of kilo 100 what
was it 100
100 kilos 100 kilos they were saying
okay we're gonna since we don't really
have a crime that fits this exact drug
we're just gonna give you the whatever
the crime would be for 100 kilos of weed
no so initially they were saying that
one gram of what we had was equivalent
to 500 grams
of marijuana oh got it so they do this i
don't know
i don't know how they get the ratio down
but they do this weird math
they convert everything to marijuana
okay and then they convert it into time
based on marijuana okay yeah i don't
know how they're gonna do that when weed
is fully legal
which i presume under this
administration it should be happening
soon and you said they do that with all
drugs they do that with all kinds of
[ __ ] they just figure out what's going
on with everybody
what's the closest to they they do some
sort of math
marijuana and then they send you based
on that conversion